انعم اليوم كان هادئا حتى قبل اللحظات
هنالك اطلاق
لرصاص ببعض الاحياء بمدينه
هذا الامر هو يعني
عملياتين لهدف سرقه بعض
المحلات هذا الامر الى ذلك اكثر من مئه
عرضه من حركات
الكليه بها محايده في هذا الصراع
الان هي على مشارك مدينه بنينا بهدف
الدخول بين المتحاربين كما قال حاكم اقليم
دارفور ليله البارحه هذه القوه عندما تصل
ستفرد السيطره على ارض الواقع وتقف بين
المتحاربين وتساهم ايضا في الجرحى والغفله
الهلال الاحمر وبعض بهذا الاهليه الان
تعمل على اجلاء الجرحى والغفله في مدينه
البنينه وهنالك عمل مجتمعي كبير بهدف
السيطره على ما خلفته الاحداث من قتلى
وجرحى ومن دمائها ومن دماء
الخدمات الانسانيه بمدينه بنينه لو تصف
لنا المشهد خلفك يبدو ان هناك حركه نزوح
من اين تاتي هذه الحركه
هنا في المينا البري وهو الميناء البري
بفرق دارفور مدينه الضعين يمكن ان نرى من
خلال هذه الخلفيه حركه اناس وحركه
القادمين من الخرطوم ايضا اليوم وفي ولايه
شرق دارفور هنالك يعني وصول كبير جدا
للمواطنين من ولايه الخرطوم وصل الى
الثلاثه الف من المواطنين قادمين من ولايه
الخرطوم فارين من المعارك في ولايه
الخرطوب وولايه شركه ديرفور تعتبر هي
واحده من الولايات الامنه جدا في اقليم
دارفور وذلك بفضل الجهات الرسميه
والادارات الاهليه التي عملت خلال الايام
الماضيه على هدنه دائمه بين الجيش ودعم
السريع كما انها عملت على تامين الاسواق
وعملت على التامين ايضا المحلات
الرسميه والمقرات الحكوميه يمكن ان نتحدث
مع بعض المواطنين في هذا اللسان ونسالهم
عن الامن هنا ونزلهم ايضا عن كيف هي
الحركه حركه الواصلين من الخرطوم معانا
عبد الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين يعني وضعنا ما
استتب تماما
والغرفه التجاريه يعني الحمد لله رب
العالمين يعني البلد وهدوا الوضع وما في
اي مشكله ونحن الان نحمد الله انه يعني
استقبلنا عدد كبير جدا جدا من الوفود
والقريبه المئه عربه من جرار
على بعض يعني كبيره جدا والحمد لله يعني
ناس البلد هنا والله ما قصروا منهم
القصائد
عنده حاجه في يده والحمد لله يعني ناس
يعني احنا نايمين على يدنا اليمنى واليدنا
ما عندنا اي احداث يعني سوقنا وسوقنا فاتح
والحمد لله رب العالمين نحمد الله يعني
كثيرا كل المناطق كل الطرمبات شغاله كل
الناس يعني مواصلين عملهم
حتى
نحمد الله نحن
ما عندنا مشكله وطبعا
[موسيقى]
عندهم
الحمد لله رب العالمين يعني الوضع مستتر
من كل الاسواق الطرفيه فاتحه الاسواق
الدول فاتحه
نحمد الله انه من الضعين الى
النهوض من الضعين الجنينه من الدائره
الفاشر يعني ما عندنا مشكله نحمد الله ما
في اي يعني اعتراض في الطريق والمواطنين
يعني ماشيين ما حيكونوا قاعدين والاربات
هذه كلها الحمد لله جاءت من الابيض من
النهود من الخرطوم
كده والوضع مستف
اي حاجه نحمد الله احنا الولايه الوحيده
في حديث
عن اكل
الناس اللي عايزين يسافروا لا لا نحن في
نحمد الله يعني وضعنا يعني على حسب الجوله
لكن برضه يعني ما اقول لك مستغلينها
تذكرتنا يعني من 25 الى 35 وحاجه بسيطه
جدا اما الان في الخرطوم ما في عربات ما
في غور التذكره حصلت 150 200 الف ولكن نحن
الحمد لله من هنا ب 25 35 50 بالس ما في
حاجه يعني خلينا انه نحن ما نسافر
عن تفلتات في الطريق عمليات سلب ونهب من
خلال هنا
المواطن في الميناء البري بمدينه الصعيد
ولايه شرق دارفور وفي كل لحظه تصل جرارات
كبيره تحمل مئات المواطنين يصلوا الى
الميناء البري مدينه
وتتفرق هذه الاعداد في الولايات فورد
المختلفه هنالك ايضا اوتر عديده وصلت هذا
المكان كل هذه الاعداد جاءت يعني فرارا من
الحرب والدائره في الخرطوم
وصلوا الى ولايه سرق دارفور هنالك مبادرات
مجتمعيه في مدينه ابو كارينكا في مدينه
عديله التابعه لولايه تقدم يعني الغذاء
للعابرين هنالك تلاحم ممتمعي رائع جدا في
ولايه شرق في دارفور مدينه
لماذا هذه المبادرات نجحت في شرق دارفور
بينما كل مناشدات والدعوات للتهدئه فشلت
في غرب دارفور وانتجت عنها هذه الاشتباكات
القبليه بعد الاشتباكات بين قوات الدعم
والجيش في الجنينه
اداره الاهليه وحكمه الجهات الرسميه في
ولايه شرق
اولا بهذا الحديث ومن بعد ذلك يعني استمع
اليها الجميع
وعمل على انجاح هذه
المبادره وهنالك الشباب هنالك قيادات ايضا
في ولايه دارفور ساهم في ايداع هذا الامر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات